you still think that the conservative
party is institutionally racist despite
the findings in this report or despite
the conclusion rather of this report
i think the findings of this report show
clearly that the conservative party is
institutionally
racist and that's based upon the
definition of what is
institutional racism but first the first
inquiry was very clear
it defines institutional racism as
and i'll quote this the collective
failure of an organization
detected in processes attitudes and
behavior
and each of those processes attitudes
and behavior
in this particular case and in the
findings of this report are found i mean
the report highlights that the
parties processes have failed and need
an overall
haul from policy to strategy to
implementation
to data collection there is a root and
branch
overhaul being done because the process
has failed from attitudes
we're hearing as part of this report
that people are still giving evidence
anonymously they don't feel confident to
add their name to the evidence of racism
that they're giving and those that do
give evidence complainants are seen
as troublemakers behavior the report
concludes that from the top
from the prime minister at one level to
local associations at the bottom
there is an attitude issue and a problem
and a behavior
issue in terms of islamophobia so on
each of those counts it
satisfies the definition of
institutional racism and
and beth you know the way i see it if it
looks like institutional racism
feels like institutional racism fits the
definition of institutional racism
then i'm afraid it is institutional
racism is boris johnson part of the
problem here
i think boris accepts that he is part of
the problem and that he got it wrong
in the past and as he says himself that
words that he used and thought he could
get away with a journalist and not the
words that would suit
a prime minister and by that what he's
admitting is that
his words are not prime ministerial they
are not acceptable that they
are insensitive towards muslim
communities and i welcome the fact that
there is now an acknowledgement that
those words whether they were used by
zach goldsmith or bob blackman or boris
johnson were insensitive and
unacceptable and i think it's right
that the party has apologized for those
but i also think that there is still
further to go
and that even with this report with some
of its positive findings and some of its
positive recommendations
still falls short because by concluding
what is so obvious
that the party does have an
institutional racism issue by concluding
that it does not it clearly shows that
there are flaws in the way in which this
inquiry was conducted flaws that i've
already pointed out
and it requires the equalities and human
rights commission to look at that
just on what the prime minister said
though he has apologized when we go back
to
calling uh muslim women uh wearing veils
bank robbers or letterboxes
he has apologized for the offense he
caused regarding those remarks
he hasn't actually apologized for making
the remarks and in the report
they say we gave him an opportunity to
apologize
uh and offered the prime minister
opportunity to apologize for his past
remarks he said the following and that
he did not wish to add anything further
and then he says i apologize for the i'm
obviously sorry for any offense taken
that's a bit of a non-apology isn't it
yeah i mean he apologizes for the
offence he caused
which means he accepts that the words
were offensive and he accepts that there
are not they are not words
that would suit a prime minister and
they are not words that he would use
now so i think you can conclude from all
of that that it is a merely mouthed
apology and you know
boris is not known to apologize but as
far as i'm concerned there is an
acceptance that what he said was wrong
what he said was offensive what he said
was insensitive
and that he would not use those words
again and i think as far as i'm
concerned we can move on from that